thank you alejandro yes we are indeed
with fabiano caruana fabi first of all
tell us how do you feel about the format
of this event it's completely new and it
seems very exciting yeah it's an
interesting format but the the really
new thing i think for the players is the
time control it's not entirely new like
we've played with with this time control
and i haven't played with it for a
decade or so
i mean it's um
it's very unforgiving because you you
never get more time
and at some point like if you're under
time pressure it's for the rest of the
game
so um yeah the 4-bat is interesting and
the time control is also quite exciting
did you do any specific preparation uh
for this time control did you play any
training games
no no i don't think you can
find someone willing to sit there for
a few hours to play you in a training
game
but i did some preparation for jeffrey
we knew the the pairings
quite a bit in advance
so
so i did some prep for him but he anyway
surprised me by playing something he had
never played before
i don't think he's ever played the
petrov so that came as quite a surprise
let's go through the game actually and
we were discussing your preparation
because we know you're getting ready for
the candidates
are you using any of the candidates prep
or are you using residual preparation
from previous uh training camps
well okay i mean you know that we
prepared this line for the world
championship match in
in 2018
um but i i didn't remember anything like
i mean it was four years ago i just
decided knight c3 is
um it's a rare move but it's transposing
to a big line which normally
um we get if black plays
let's say knight c6 instead of bishop f5
knight c6
castle
bishop e7 knight c3 bishop f5 this is
the usual move order yeah
so
and then we get the game position
and knight c3 and bishop f5
so
so i was hoping he wouldn't be too
familiar with the line and that seemed
to be
the
case but i also
had no familiarity with the line
i think like the main move is queen f5
or rp1 but rookie 2 caught him
off guard it seemed very logical to me
during the game so
i went with it i'm just trying to double
rooks and i i was very happy with the
position i got i thought i got a very
pleasant amount of pressure
um
yeah i was sort of happy with bishop b5
although it might not i mean it's not
forced of course
i have a number of options including
just taking on d6
but bishop b5 i i liked how it kept the
tension in the position
and yeah then he surprised me
with b5 right
um
i thought queen e3 was clever because
now he's under this very annoying pin
um but
maybe it wasn't the best
uh
look i'm kind of pinned but he's also
pinned so it's it's hard to say
who's pinned and here he shocked me with
king f7 i was expecting
something else but king f7 allows queen
h6 queen f4 right i figured his idea was
queen f4 king g7 he wants to sacrifice
the c7 pawn get into an end game where
um i'm a pawn but c3 is a very big
weakness
why did you reject queen h6
yeah this was a definitely correct queen
of six king james and knight h2
i realized this after i played knight h2
that
this was the right way to play
that you could have done this instead
it's like the game but he doesn't have
the h5 option right and if bishop f8
knight uh queen to f4 exactly
and now knight g4 is really a big threat
in fact this is real really dangerous
for black yes um
what i missed when i played knight h2
i thought i was
paralyzing him h5 queen f3 but i missed
b4
and
yeah and here i was kind of happy with
this rookie six idea
um bishop h4 i thought i should be much
better but maybe i shouldn't take on c3
it turns out that this is actually the
key moment yeah i was thinking about g4
here and that was the that was the
alternative which is actually according
to the engine super strong for you yeah
uh what did you look at or did you just
think okay i can always come back to you
i thought after g4 he has to take
knight takes yeah well you could take on
c3 first i think right
now
i thought that was what we're looking at
you can indeed take on c3 and then
knight takes g4
yeah i didn't consider this i was
looking at my g4 immediately and then f5
and this one i didn't really consider
um
i guess it's also quite strong for white
because yeah i can play queen c3 here
and um probably take on e7 knight e3 at
some point and just have
um
a much much better version of the game
he doesn't have the activity in the game
it was actually a big surprise for us
that
when you played the move queen c3
and he has pl once he played the move
rook b8 he's right in the game yeah i i
was also surprised i thought i would be
in time to coordinate but
exactly not at all my king is very weak
so what happened here king d7 knight f1
repeat yeah and this is already
things have you've lost yeah yeah i
didn't see anything
i was even starting i mean it should be
a draw but i was starting to worry that
my king could get under attack
and yeah maybe king g2 because i
well at this point we were both low on
time i was trying to make sure i didn't
get into
terrible time pressure exactly and it's
such a difficult position to
because it's just pure tactics at this
point you know there is no
nothing really guides you here
right general principles be damned
discover check and rook f4 yeah i was
already getting worse
near the end but
maybe it was always a draw
but i was worried that
you know white white is the one who has
to make a draw here black has no risk
exactly
and that was the belligerent move queen
a7 then just at the end it did turn out
that there was a three-move repetition
um
but uh jeffrey was one was the one who
wanted to be sure i mean obviously at
this point you're ready to claim the
draw yeah he was thinking about how to
um play this he mentioned the move
knight f5 here okay
um
after queen d4 queen d4 knight f5 yet
queen h8 king b7
okay
and
knight d5
i really need to get the activity rook
takes a2
and what he was worried about he told me
was queen to c3
but it seems like he has this move rook
six to e2
again it's very complicated it's um but
if i don't have checks i could also lose
right i started to lose all my pawns
queen before the king hides on c6 which
is very important
so he was afraid of this no no he was he
didn't see rook e2 uh so he was thinking
the rook on a2 would be in series
when he didn't see the move rookie too
well thank you very much for joining us
fabi and sharing your thoughts of this
uh first day thank you thank you and we
are done with the first day are we yeah
the two